we're really pleased to have reached the
milestone of pi million subscribers
here's the moment imagined at YouTube
headquarters we'd like to thank
everybody who helps make the videos who
appears in the videos and of course most
importantly you the people who watch the
videos and to celebrate the occasion
some of our friends are going to help us
remind you or some of those first digits
of pi are starting of course with
3.14159265 three five eight nine seven
nine three two three four seven four six
two six four three three eight three two
seven teen five zero two eight eight
four one nine seven one six nine one
three nine nine three seven five right
one zero five eight two zero no nine
four four five nine two three zero seven
eight one six zero six two eight six two
zero eight nine nine eight six two eight
zero three
for eight two five three four two one
one seven zero six seven nine eight two
one four eight zero eight six five one
three two eight two three zero six six
nine three eight I think you probably
get the idea now and as an extra thank
you to those people who sent in some
digits I've uploaded some outtakes so
you can see just how hard it is counting
from nought to nine also see the
description for details of all the
people in today's video and hopefully
we'll see you again really soon and of
course it's not too late to subscribe we
want to get to tau a million one day